first and foremost uh you are a streamer
chess streamer and a superstar uh in in
that field and um we would like to to
discuss that a little bit and take us
back to like the early days of chess
streaming and how chess bra started
uh yeah um well i was uh in college in
the in the us um
one of the universities that offers
chess scholarships and uh
i was playing a lot of chess at the time
i've always played a lot online and uh
i was noticing that people were
were starting to um stream their
perspectives in other games uh shooting
games that i was following some other
ones and
i just uh decided to start trying it out
a little bit um well it kind of starts
like this in canada
it's a big country small chess community
so
i had a lot of friends and we'd play in
nationals
like every country has a youth
championships but otherwise you might be
three four thousand kilometers away for
the rest of the year even you make your
friends and you don't really see each
other so you know usually chatting on
skype and hanging out
um
and then because these are chess friends
we'd hang out sometimes somebody plays
and no come online and watch me
so that
that kind of social environment we had
kind of made sense you know
the streaming things um
starting to
become a bit more popular how about
somebody just streams and we just go
hang out and watch them there if there's
already a platform that allows that so
um
originally it was just like kind of a
friend hangout hey i'm gonna go like win
100 rating points or go like
you know everyone has a you know we've
been addicted to bullet or blitz at some
point and just playing for hours on end
and
and uh
nice to have a few friends watching or
suffering with you so sorry i like that
a little bit just the way to socialize
and connect with
people you're already chatting with but
i did see that
it was gaining in popularity
in games where
people really benefited from seeing a
personal perspective
um first person so to speak so
part of it was social but part of it was
like you know i could see this becoming
um a much bigger part of the internet in
the future for uh gaming and competitive
well esports at the time esports wasn't
really a word as much
back then it was just starcraft if i
remember in a few games but
it was it looked like it had potential
and uh
i don't know i i guess i always grew up
because i started playing blitz mainly
online and just mainly online i played a
lot of computer games i always believed
that was the future because i was raised
on the internet that hey this is only
going to get more popular and more
people are going to
watch and have competitive events so i
was always a little optimistic that
these kind of formats would eventually
become mainstream
and then yeah as i said for myself
though personally i always enjoyed
playing in front of people so at a local
chess club if i was playing blitz i
don't mind if there's a crowd there
don't mind if people are betting on it
doesn't matter just the more people the
more fun
so
doing that online you have the potential
for
for a much larger crowd much larger
reach
but yeah originally it really did start
as a
bit of a hobby with friends just to just
to hang out while we're all all in
different cities